what's up everyone how's it going it's
good to see all you beautiful people out
here today what's up what's up thank you
for coming out thank you for zeal center
for the space greatly appreciate it I'm
really looking forward to this talk and
it's nice to be back in Sioux Falls for
those that don't know I'm a Sioux Falls
native I was a born and raised here and
then I went to Minneapolis for two years
and then I moved out to Silicon Valley
and now I host a show called simulation
which features scientists entrepreneurs
artists educators different thought
leaders and we do live events we do a
studio show and it's been a lot of fun
learning from a lot of diverse people
and synthesizing a bunch of knowledge
across different fields which will be
kind of one of the thesis 'iz of what we
talked about today I hope that people
leave inspired wanting to pursue
entrepreneurship pursue what is
meaningful in their lives and ride the
exponential technology curves that are
that are transforming our world that
crazy rates so let's get some energy can
I get some energy yeah yeah yeah good
okay cool cool all right
so so there's a couple central axioms
which are truths that I want to sort of
these self-evident truths that I want to
lay as a foundation for the rest of the
talk those axioms are one ignorant is
the root of malice so ignorant is the
root of bad things too
education is the vaccine to ignorant
and as we know we mold children into our
world so how do we educate those
children into our world to be as least
ignorant and most knowledgeful as
possible and three big history is the
best mental model of Education so we're
gonna talk about why I believe big
history is the vaccine to ignorant so
what is big history big history can be
summarized by the cosmos life the
evolution of life and then the evolution
of humanity and the the breakdown of
this right net right actually I'm gonna
go over here and use my hands so when
you synthesize all of knowledge into
some sort of a a story this story is
continuously unfolding and your role is
somewhere in this story over here of
course and so what is your character's
role in this unfolding story and why is
it important to build out this mental
model of big history and then build on
top of that for every single child
that's moved moving forward and being
born into our world so this this
timeline of 13.7 billion years what the
timeline itself from this perspective is
the the majority of time is actually
here so there's somewhere around nine or
so nine to ten billion years that are
right here so it's a vast majority of
the time and then this is sort of opened
up especially this side is only looks
like you know fifty thousand years so
our time is a grain of sand on this
entire on this entire spectrum of time
but understanding the evolution of the
cosmos understanding the evolution of
life on Earth and then on
standing how humans have evolved on the
planet is a key framework and mental
model for children and for eradicating
ignorance eradicating malice and
figuring out how to best prosper
together so how do you guys feel about
this so far it's liking this ok cool
cool cool cool we're on a conversational
base so if you guys want to chime in say
something go for it yeah cool stellar
there's a hey yeah I get it alright so
this sort of multidisciplinary synthesis
it not only it not only is history in
this term big history but it's also
science
it's probing reality with hypothesis
hypotheses and then testing those over
time over and over again making sure
those are true that gravity is true that
the molecular composition of water is
true that the way that we uncover
different artifacts from civilization is
true that they live that way they built
language that way so we're using the
tools of history we're using tools of
science and we're using the tools of
sociology understanding the complex sort
of cybernetic systems that exist in the
last especially several thousand years
that have really taken civilization from
a population of a couple million people
to seven point seven billion complex
individuals that all have their own
families lives work culture and
perspective so building off this overall
picture is a huge huge importance in
moving forward and education for as we
bring children into our world so I think
this is the strongest mental model
as you saw in the beginning chunk of of
the evolution of the cosmos we saw earth
and how crazy is it that we somehow
managed to get life on this planet and
that we are everyone that's ever lived
and died everything that's ever been
built has been built on that rock
orbiting the star that gives us life and
that is such a profound sense of
awakening and wonder - how can I
possibly be so tribalists and stuck in
my views that I would be willing to kill
you for money for greed for power for
land for religion for any of those
things when we're just sharing one Rock
as one tribe called Earth how many of
you feel that it's a divinity that we're
here do you guys feel like it's divine
that we're here yeah
yeah the sunset was gorgeous there was
some cotton candy in there and it has
been a glass couple of some sunrises and
sunsets have been just amazing in Sioux
Falls and there is some sort of
something that's ethereal it's it's it's
it's you can't really wrap it around
wrap it's like water we're trying to
grasp water the sense of divinity this
and so whatever has given us this
pleasure of Harvey of the evolution of
life on this planet we we take it with
gratitude we take it with bliss we take
it with how do I play my role in
stewardship for Earth and in maximizing
my own potential and collective
potential so when you look at Earth from
here there's no borders the borders are
important but they're also they're also
completely manufactured by us just like
the illusion of money is as well these
sorts of they separate us temporarily
but in the long term I think we will be
flourishing altogether so there's
something strange that potentially
exists outside of Earth how many of us
have felt something potentially greater
than ourselves past ourselves absolutely
yeah in the back over here yeah yeah
this there's something deeper beyond the
three-dimensional physical reality that
we live in that we're still trying to
identify exactly what it is God
consciousness all that is infinity what
is this what are these potential powers
that take play here on earth through us
all right probably one of my favorite
images of all time as well
the reason why is because this is this
is civilization this is how we got to
where we are at today and it took us a
long time every single one of these
individuals built something into our
world of value that we are now reaping
the benefits of today that we are now
privileged in using today shelter food
water energy all ubiquitous they're
everywhere
it's everywhere look at this light in
here look at all the water and the food
that we have on every corner it's
incredible it's humbling expressing the
gratitude for the humans that went
through all the sacrifices that they
have in order to bring us here is one of
the most profound ways that we can join
a you communion a communion with of
evolution with each other of
understanding how we actually got here
and how we are able to prosper moving
forward as you see some we got some we
got some great fire use here we have
some great agriculture here we have some
great use of animals and use of tools
here and here as well
shelter being built so the sort of
techniques and mental models that were
evolved over time again what were they
teaching their children what are we
teaching our children now
who innovated these things who is the
[ __ ] the ones that decided to make a
wheel and the wheels are still on the
cars today they're here thousands of
years later what will be made today that
will still be here thousands of years
later thinking about the innovations
that were made this inspires us to think
about what innovations we can make today
and how we can design civilization to
maximize flourishing so as you look at
some of these ancestors here isn't it
also interesting to think about my my
mother is here in the audience today who
who were her parents who were their
parents what about their parents and
their parents and their parents and
their parents and their parents hundreds
hundreds thousands of years of lineage
who are they where does this ancestry go
who are your parents and their parents
great-great great-great grandparents
that slowly built families that over
time produced you into the world and how
can we be grateful for them and how can
we better build out a mental model that
shows them respect that we understand
what they went through and built to get
us here
I like to think of I like to think of
meaning as the zone so when you're doing
something that you lose track of time
that you're so focused on the objective
that you're doing and that you just love
what you're doing that that feeling
right there is meaning to me and I think
the more that I see people that are at
the sort of zone where the work that
they're doing is not so so hard that
they can't achieve it and that it's not
too easy where it's just child's play
for them but words just at the peak of
how difficult they can actually operate
and manage something and and build it
and they love what they do with that
process of building and creating that
that is meaning how many of you guys
build something that you love every
single day and what about the others why
not
most days not every day's fun yeah and
what what sort of what sort of changes
would need to happen in our lives in
order to make it so that every day as
much as possible even through those
challenges where we saw as growth we saw
that as continuously leveling up and
pursuing what is meaningful there's only
a certain amount of time as we saw with
the big history breakdown we're all we
were all the way at this end at the very
very end our little period of hopefully
80 years of time hopefully that we get
about 25,000 days about 2.5 billion
seconds or 2.5 billion heartbeats that's
all we get in being alive every day
matters every minute matters everything
that we do with our time matters
pursuing what we find to be most
meaningful and important to us another
really important aspect to time is the
idea of neural real estate or just the
way that your brain is structured the
architecture of your mind because when
you are expanding the mental models of
children to understand civilization in
its deepest of nuance they build out a
strong mental model their neural real
estate is able to be built on top of
really well and if we're choosing to
frequently endeavor into what is most
meaningful for us building raising kids
or whatever that is that we keep
focusing on that and building that
versus potentially being distracted and
there's a lot of people that are aiming
to distract us away from what is most
meaningful in order for money to be made
the attention economy so don't forget
that every moment what we do with our
time is so critical so so critical and
the way that we fill our mind with
stimuli is so critical I have a running
joke of of beer gardens and Netflix and
that's been something that is fulfilling
for certain people and that's very
important to identify that these are not
good versus bad I like hustling on what
I'm building and I think that if we can
teach kids to focus on hustling on what
they're building I think we'll see a lot
more entrepreneurship and innovation in
our world and boom in the blink of an
eye here we are we are at the
exponential technology age
after so much time of civilization we
are just now finally at the exponential
technology age we are all living in it
and it's insane to think about because
it it expands into every single field of
humanity
there's not one field that is not being
touched in some way by exponential
technologies by the internet by
computing by artificial intelligence
every single field and when we think
about it in terms of in terms of code we
maybe gain a way of perceiving reality
that can help us understand things for
example when I mentioned earlier that we
get about 2 and 1/2 billion seconds we
get about 25,000 days to live do we get
a control our heart we aren't speaking
terms yeah yeah do we get to control our
heartbeat our heart beats and it beats
and it beats throughout our entire life
we can exercise we can increase the
heart rate we can meditate we can
potentially decrease the heart rate but
our heart just keeps beating no matter
how hard we try and we can see that as
code we can see that when you get hungry
you eat we can write these things as
code so we start perceiving reality as
oh the earth is 93 million miles from
the Sun and it orbits the Sun every 365
0.25 days
point whatever it is ish yeah so
why don't we start writing these things
into code we sort of start seeing the
world in a different way what are what
is the code that governs our biology the
ast CS and G's that we can rewrite our
genetics that we can eradicate disease
that we can reprogram stem cells to
proliferate and make clean meat instead
of slaughtering animals we can grow it
in bio reactors and that is just by oh
that's just biology that's just the code
of biology then there's the code of
neurology there's the code of your mind
and there's the way that we are limited
right now with our meat sticks pressing
fingers on keyboards that the reason why
this is being recorded is because
there's a greater bandwidth in
communication even that just that last
sentence there how much data can be
stored in that last sentence plus via
video then how slow can you actually
just press your fingers on a keyboard
trying to type what I just said and how
much data is lost don't get the video
component so as we connect computers
even more intimately with our minds we
enter a whole new world of bandwidth a
whole new world of being able to connect
to all information to all knowledge at
unprecedented rates for the good and the
bad there's a lot of ethical concerns
around bio bio technology around neuro
technology around artificial
intelligence and we need to work
together to figure out those ethical
quandaries and we need to teach kids to
care about those ethical quandaries that
we doubt face us another pertinent
exponential technology is quantum
mechanics
quantum programming quantum computing
quantum security understanding the most
micro mechanisms of the universe and how
does that funnel into energy a ubiquity
and clean energy it's time for us to
completely transition over to
sustainable sources of energy for
civilization and help inspire children
to care about that as well and the
quantum world helps us with nuclear
energy with figuring out how we can fuse
atoms and produce more energy than we
put in and that's an abundant source an
unlimited source just like the Sun is of
energy becoming multiplanetary is
extremely important and we figure out
how to launch rockets and reuse rockets
in the space economy we'll be moving
faster than ever like we are right now
putting satellites putting Rovers into
space building out the space economy and
making consciousness multiplanetary to
avoid a catastrophe like happened 66
million years ago with the dinosaurs
humans like to think they're in control
we are in many ways in control of earth
now it's the anthropic see the human
controlled period but we also are at the
mercy of the cosmos obliterating us and
ourselves obliterating each other and we
have to do our best to prevent that and
that's what our ancestors would want so
artificial intelligence is permeating
through every single industry as well
robotics is automating processes even
doing things like automating creativity
we didn't think that we would have
artificial intelligence that can make
music now it makes music what's next
what's next what do we do what do we do
how do we train the kids to be robot
proof and of course another one of the
most important technologies that has yet
to be listed blockchain and
cryptocurrency
building trust the code of trust the
code of a decentralized digital ledger
that's immutable for everything that we
want to write on it that's the way we're
going
enough with the centralization of power
decentralize it to all people and enable
all people to have an equality of
opportunity to flourish with these
different technologies this also is very
deeply reminds us of augmented reality
and virtual reality in living in worlds
that are completely programmable and
designed we were talking about these
variables your heart beating you get
hungry you got to go eat the star is a
certain distance from the planet the
planet orbits a certain amount of time
you'll get to program what realities you
want to live in or live in other
people's realities that they program how
often will you come back to this base
reality is this even base reality
and as we were just mentioning having
equality of opportunity is so crucial
these technologies are not only going to
be made available to the wealthy over
time they become democratized they
become decentralized over time more and
more people are able to access these
technologies it's up to us to make sure
that that actually happens and that
everyone around the world gets access to
the technology and enables them to
maximize their potential providing
people with those economic degrees of
freedom to move in whatever way they
want that brings the meaning so building
building creating innovating pursuing
what is meaningful to you is so so
important all right some of you know
that I've been to for ten day meditation
retreats silent meditation retreats no
talking no eye contact no technology and
all of this the snow in a snow globe is
what we're doing every single day just
walking around the snow globe shaking
this is what we're doing all day long
but when do we go when do we close our
eyes when we take a deep breath when do
we turn off the stimuli when do we to an
inward and what what does that do for us
how does that change our physiology how
does that change our creativity how does
that change our gratitude and our love
it profoundly changes those things and
it's so important to be silent even for
five minutes a day close your eyes
tune in word use a meditation app if you
have to but just slow down and do that
process and watch what happens
express gratitude during that time for
your mother for your father for the food
for the electricity for whatever you
have express gratitude for it there's a
lot of time that I have this crazy
feeling of recomm yuning with the
infinite when I'm in meditation what
does that even mean I don't know chards
on it it's ridiculous but it's so
profoundly interesting alright I have
something that I'm borrowing a little
bit from Mark Twain here
Mark Twain says that travel is fatal to
prejudice bigotry and narrow mindedness
what's true so it was big history we all
understand we're from the same rock why
am I gonna be prejudice why am I gonna
be bigoted that when I understand all of
the nuance the multi variability I
become more compassionate I have a
stronger mental model that I build out
of reality and without that drive for
nuance and multi variability and
building out that mental model this
cannot be acquired by vegetating and in
ego
it can't be acquired by vegetating in a
unit dimensional mentality of reality
some of some of you potentially have
seen the TEDx talk that I gave in San
Francisco in October the binary trap is
killing us we're falling into black or
white on so many issues but when we look
for the nuance on the multi variability
and the the non unit dimensionality the
multidimensionality we start seeing how
all of this actually ties together and
how we can have really good
conversations together
big history is the vaccine to ignorance
and let's build out this basic framework
for all children and let's continue
augmented overtime build the future go
and create go and build our society
counts on you to innovate much love
thank you thank you